You've You've helped me make my case.
What I wanted to show you is the very
passages we consider Messianic
your rabbis did. I'm not saying it means
Jesus
You do? Of course. I said this right at
the beginning. Okay, hold on. No, no.
So, you mean you like this one here?
This is because that will be It'll make
me happy if you admit this. I'm glad you
do, but here.
Okay.
Cuz I If you have time, let me know when
you got to go because I wanted to talk
about Rashi's timeline of Daniel. But
here, you agree
>> We'll have to do it next time. Okay, how
much time do you have now?
About Well, it's 7:41 now.
Um So, you want to end it now? It's up
to you. I've got 20 minutes maximum.
Okay. All right. Let me just go through
some of these. See, I want because I
just want to And we'll talk about
Daniel's timeline another time if you
want to. You got my Skype.
Okay, so you agree then Micah 5:1,
Bethlehem, the ruler the ruler according
to
Messiah son of David, right? Yeah. Yeah.
But then he also says Psalm 118:22 is
about Messiah. The stone the builders
had reject became a cornerstone.
See it? Yeah, it's a drash.
It's what? It's a drash. I It's a It's
an eisegesis. It's saying that um It
It's saying that this verse can be
applied to the Messiah, yeah. Doesn't
mean that it is in simple read, what we
call pshat. In In simple read, nothing
to the Messiah. But in drash, which is
what Rashi is doing here, um you can
apply it to the Messiah. Okay. All
right. I'm glad you explained it. But
So, you agree though that Micah 5, the
ruler will come out of Bethlehem and
that he is the stone the builders had
reject became a cornerstone. How was the
Messiah rejected?
Um because um because Bethlehem is
something that had been rejected.
But it says he is the one that's
rejected and Psalm 118 doesn't talk
about Bethlehem.
It doesn't talk about the Messiah,
either. It This as I said is an
eisegesis. It's a drash, right? Um the
the the
What?
You're shaking
>> to let you finish. I don't want to cut
you off because I'm I'm it's killing me
that I have to keep But go ahead, finish
your point. So Um the
When it says that the stone the builders
has and rejected became a cornerstone Um
so what what we get what I'm getting
from this at least is that
is is that you would never have thought
that
that something that something good could
have come out of Bethlehem. I I the
stone
is um it is is the is the place I the
whole the whole
the whole thing of the Messiah son of
Messiah son of David coming from
Bethlehem, you would never have expected
that to become the cornerstone.
So what's becoming the cornerstone from
Bethlehem it's its lineage coming from
Bethlehem, you would never have thought
that this that this that this stone
could become the cornerstone. But do you
understand why that's not going to make
sense, right?
Let me try to explain to you because
this is why I said I'm laughing. Why
would they be shocked the Messiah would
come out of Bethlehem rejected when
David is a Bethlehemite and they
accepted him as king? What are you
talking about, Josh?
Josh, what are you talking about? That's
why I laughed. I'm letting you finish.
See guys, I'm doing this as a lesson
because the people say, "Sam, you're
mean. That's why people don't talk to
you." My brother in humanity, son of
Adam.
By the time this prophecy was made,
David had arisen. He was the king of
Judah and he's a Bethlehemite. So no one
would reject Bethlehem anymore.
So you're That's why I let you just keep
talking and talking.
>> one, sorry, I interrupted you. Go ahead,
yeah. Go on. What's verse one, yes? In
verse one it says that Bethlehem is
least among the clans of Judah.
>> We know it says that, but my point is
that for this to mean that they're
shocked the ruler came out of Bethlehem,
why the hell weren't they then shocked
when David was appointed king when he
came out of Bethlehem?
They were.
Okay,
one more time, my friend.
Let's go with what you just said, they
were. Once David was established and his
sons were disestablished, would anyone
now have a problem that God brought a
king out of Bethlehem because now
David's established and they accepted
him?
Afterwards
Afterwards, no. Good.
Okay. Now let's go back. I think that
this is coming from the from from the
from the prior perspective. And the
reason I think that is because it's
still calling
in this verse, which is clearly about
the Messiah, it's still calling
Bethlehem the least of the clans even
though this is well after David's Yes.
And that's why it's saying out of this
place, look at God has honored it. David
came from it and this ruler is going to
come from it. So that which was least
has now become great because let's
finish it. Okay, so
and you Bethlehem Ephrathah, you should
have been the lowest, you should have.
But look how God has honored you. Not
only did David come from you and his
line, the king the kingly line
established through David, but this one
will come also, but his origin is from
old, from days of yore. I'll get to that
maybe in part three because your time is
running out, but what I want to show is
Psalm 118, you say it's not Messianic.
Well, I'm going to show you why they
said it's Messianic. I'll get there,
brother.
But I just want for the sake
I understand your point.
If we follow your logic that Bethlehem
was rejected, are you saying Bethlehem
is the stone or the king is the stone?
I think they are basic kind of one in
the same. I
I the Messiah being this important guy
from the from the the the the main
family of Bethlehem, which was the the
family of Boaz through Obed through
Yishai. Um so so they kind of represent
Bethlehem. So it's kind of one in the
same.
Now I'm going to show you why
I told you when you say, "Well, it
doesn't say Messiah either, but why did
they think it's Messianic?" And it has
nothing to do with Bethlehem. So now in
this context, we're going to just stay
with this context. Let's read. The stone
that the builders rejected became a
cornerstone. This was wise from the
Lord. It is wondrous in our eyes. This
is the day that the Lord made. We shall
exalt rejoice thereon.
Please, O Lord, save now. Please, O
Lord, make prosperous now. Blessed is be
he who comes in the name of the Lord. We
have blessed you from the house of Lord.
This is why they took it as Messianic.
The one who'll come in the name of the
Lord. So if I just read this in the
context,
it has nothing to do with Bethlehem
being the stone that's rejected.
Nothing.
It has to do with the one that they're
expecting to come. Why was he rejected?
I'd like to know why you think that it's
verse 26 that is the reason for the
eisegesis that Rashi has done.
I I'd like to know that cuz that doesn't
It's quite It seems to be quite a leap
from my perspective. I'm not sure what
you mean.
I'm trying to see where to begin so I
can show you that the reason why this
was taken as Messianic because when they
are praying, they're blessing the one
who comes in the name of the Lord
because this has connections to other
Psalms that are considered about the
king like Psalm 72. That's why Rashi
connected it with Psalm 72. You see?
See and this is why it's
I have to make these connections for
you, but let So now do Do accept it now?
Do I have to prove it?
That's That verse 18 is the reason?
That's
22 to 26, they saw the connection
between this poem. Say it again. Sorry,
I meant verse 26. I got got the Yeah,
you know why? Because here, I'll show
you why here.
Here, because see, it's right here,
buddy. That's why Rashi connected Psalm
72, "May his name be forever, before the
sun his name will be magnified, and
people will bless themselves with him.
All nations will praise him." That's
why, friend. Do I really need to spell
it out, man? Right. That's fine. Okay,
so we got it why Psalm 118:26
is connected with Psalm 118:20
which is then interpreted as Messiah
because Rashi is seeing and Rabbi is
seeing, "Oh, we have similar themes
about the king in other Psalms." Did I
make my case now? Sure. Sure. Okay, so
now let's go back. You see, and let me
know when your time is up.
Psalm 118:22,
"The stone that the builders rejected
became a cornerstone."
So, how do I know this is referring to a
Messiah? Because here it says, "Blessed
be he who has come in the name of the
Lord. We have blessed you from the house
of the Lord." And that connects with
other themes about the king, Psalm 72,
which is also interpreted messianically.
So, now what I want to ask you,
what
did the king do that led to your people
rejecting him and then later realizing
their mistake? Why was he rejected?
Again, I think this is
Again, I I I don't see how this goes
against what I was saying before about
about the Messiah being a representative
of Bethlehem. I don't see how that goes
against it at all.
All right, well, what we'll do is, cuz
time is running out, God willing, part
three, I want to talk about Daniel's
timeline and Messiah's appearance
according to Rashi. You let me know when
you want to do it, friend. You got my
Skype, all right? Yeah. That that that
that that there is something else that
I'd like to talk about in in the next
time. And what is it? Which is
which is the difference between the
which is going
Actually, yeah, the timeline is pretty
is pretty good discussion to have. Yeah,
we'll see whether Jesus is Messiah or
not. That's the whole point. I mean,
yeah, that that that that that that that
really should have been today's thing.
Um Well, I had to foreshadow you that
the prophecies I'm going to appeal to.
Why do you think I'm doing this?
Our prophecies that even the rabbis
admit are about Messiah, and then I'm
going to have to make the case that's
Jesus. Why do you think I did this? I'm
trying to show you someone who
>> you that at the beginning, man. I told
you that an hour ago. I told you that.
So, you admit it. So, when I go and
quote, "Hey, well, this prophecy we
believe Jesus fulfilled." No, it's not
about Messiah. We're not going to do
that, right?
No, I'm not I'm not going to say
I'm I'm not going to
I I I told you at the beginning And do
you acknowledge
the way I look at exclusive exclusive
passages versus inclusive passages.
But do you admit that rabbinic Judaism
also affirms the preexistence of
Messiah?
That he's actually still he's alive, he
was with God from the days of creation?
That that the that the idea of the
Messiah was created
>> No, he himself.
No, he himself
has been with God from the days of
creation, Pesiqta Rabbati?
I'm not sure. I'll have to look into
that. All right. Well, yeah, I can give
you the other quote. good place to
that's probably a good place to leave it
for next time. Okay, let me know next
time. We'll talk. I'm going to show you
from the Pesiqta Rabbati interpreting
Psalm 22, which we take to about
Messiah, about Messiah being there from
the days of creation with God under the
throne. Pesiqta Rabbati, we'll talk
about it part three. God willing, let me
know when.
All right, then.
All right. Um yeah, we'll we'll speak.
You let you contact me. I'm free anytime
this week. You let me know. God bless.
Okay, I'm I'm not free for the rest of
this week. I've got a wedding tomorrow
and what what's up? Sunday you told me
Sunday let me know. Why Saturday you
know? Sunday yeah, Sunday should be
good.
you know
Sunday
Let me know Sunday we'll set it up. All
right then.
Everybody take care.
Baruch Hashem.
Okay guys. All right, I hope you enjoyed
it guys. We're done.
All right, so
Lord willing
Josh fight toy out because I'm going to
be shutting down. So don't take
personally.
Lord willing
If you want me to come back tonight
I can come back and do another session
later tonight, but I need you guys to
pray for me.